[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain a japanese manga series
adapted into a movie called the promised
neverland
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
at the beginning of the movie an 11 year
old girl named emma gets up from her bed
and wakes other children sleeping in the
same hall they live in a massive
orphanage called the grace field house
where all their needs are taken care of
they are guided by a woman named
isabella who the kids call their mom
although the kids aren't tied by blood
they live like one large family and
receive much love from their mom their
mornings start when emma wakes everyone
up then they sit together and enjoy
varieties of healthy food the children's
education and happiness are given the
first priority in the orphanage they are
taught inside the premises of the
orphanage like any other school emma and
two of her best friends norman and rey
always excel in their studies and get
the highest scores the children also
have identifying numbers tattooed on
them and have no knowledge of the
outside world the orphanage is
surrounded by a large meadow where the
kids run around and play together
however they are never allowed to go
outside the fence that surrounds the
meadow the kids all arrive at the
orphanage as infants but they do not
stay there for their whole life it is
arranged for them to be adopted by their
foster parents and go to the outside
world to meet new people similarly a
little girl named connie leaves the
orphanage one day the kids send her off
after wishing her well and tell her to
be good to her new parents next isabella
takes little connie to the entrance of
the orphanage meanwhile emma finds a
stuffed toy that connie loves and runs
outside with norman to return it to her
they reach the entrance gate and see
that isabella and connie have already
passed through the two take a chance and
slowly step outside where they find a
single van and no one around as they
look inside the van the duo is horrified
connie lies limp on the floor with a
plant stabbed into her chest before they
can react two grotesque creatures
approach them emma and norman hide under
the van frozen in shock the creatures
talk to each other about human meat
being the best one of them claims that
the meat coming from this farm is elite
and is saved for the rich demons the
kids from their hiding realize that
their orphanage is only a farm where
they are raised like cattle only to be
eaten by demons the students are
classified as good meat when they are
more intelligent just then isabella
arrives there and talks to the demons
about the students who got the highest
score in the class those students are
the most delicious ones and the ones who
are in demand isabella had been
schooling them to make them taste better
for the demons she promises to bring the
highest scoring children the next time
norman and emma narrowly escape without
being seen and run to the orphanage emma
falls down crying midway claiming that
the girl they saw was not connie and
refusing to believe their mom can be
this evil norman tries to calm her down
and says that they can run away from the
orphanage but emma is worried for the
other children who are like family to
her the following day emma and norman
talk about the events of the previous
day norman suggests they plan an
elaborate escape from the orphanage and
not tell the others before the plan is
completed they decide to cross the fence
that day to see exactly what the outside
world is like after walking through the
woods for a while they reach a tall wall
they cannot jump across it so they
return
meanwhile a little girl named nayla gets
lost in the forest isabella looks into
her watch and brings nayla back in no
time emma and norman see this and
realize that the watch is a transmitter
with which she knows where all the kids
are the following day norman and emma go
to the woods with a rope which they plan
on using to cross the wall just then
they are caught by their best friend ray
who is suspicious of them norman reveals
the truth about the orphanage toure
telling him everything they heard and
saw that night in contrast to what the
two had thought ray believes them almost
immediately he claims that they should
run away from the orphanage as soon as
possible but emma insists that they
shouldn't leave the other kids behind to
be eaten at night isabella introduces
everyone to their new caretaker crone
crone's arrival makes it more difficult
for the group to escape
then we see isabella and crone talking
when isabella reveals that she found
connie's toy and is aware that emma
norman and rey know about the
orphanage's true motive however she is
confident they won't escape later the
three set off to talk in private norman
believes that someone among the children
is isabella's spy who provides her with
all the information if this is true they
know that someone from the older
children should be one the group decides
to tell two of the older children don
and gilda about the reality of the
orphanage they do not believe the kids
at first but eventually agree to help
them once the three are alone norman
says that he told don and gilda two
different locations of the ropes that
they are about to use to climb the wall
the one that will disappear first will
reveal who is the spy the next day one
of the ropes disappears emma and rey are
happy that they found the spy but norman
instead reveals that the rope story was
a trap for rey he had told rey a fake
location to find out if he was the spy
and rey fell into the trap ray finally
admits that he discovered the
orphanage's truth a long time ago and
knew that he couldn't escape he
confronted isabella who said that no
matter what he will be given to a demon
one day so with no way out he
volunteered to be a spy for her so that
she would delay his adoption however rey
hasn't told isabella about the
children's plan to use the rope to climb
the wall which makes norman believe rey
isn't loyal to her then rey reveals that
he has been planning to escape for a
long time
in fact he was the one who stole
connie's toy so that emma and norman
could find the truth and would try
running away too norman declares rey as
a double spy and keeps him on the team
at night ray goes to isabella and
falsely reports to her about norman
trying to poison her food isabella
thanks him but in turn says that rey's
turn to be adopted is drawing near the
next day all five of the children are
planning to jump over the wall when
crone overhears them talking but instead
of reporting to isabella she joins them
it turns out that crone was also a
student like them she wants to remove
isabella and be the new mother of the
orphanage and for that she is ready to
help the kids at night they visit her
room where crone tells them everything
she knows about the outside world over 1
000 years ago men and demons were at war
after a long and tedious battle both
creatures decided not to bother each
other anymore an agreement called the
promise was made according to which both
humans and demons would live in their
own separate worlds some humans were
left behind in the demon world and that
is how the humans breeding farms started
by eating intelligent humans demons take
on their attributes which prevents them
from turning into mindless monsters this
also benefits the humans hence they
sacrificed a few on the farm so the
world could be at peace the very next
day isabella fires crone because she
somehow found out about her intentions
while leaving crohn sees their
supervisor grandmother at the gate she
makes a demon eat crone for trying to
help the kids the kids then execute
their plan emma and norman go to the
wall while rey stalls isabella and the
other two keep an eye on her however
their plan soon fails when isabella
locks rey inside a room and goes to
catch norman and emma herself she finds
them near the wall and finally confronts
them claiming she has given them
everything they want in life so they
shouldn't resist the inevitable
emma tries to stop isabella and as they
struggle she breaks emma's leg she then
informs norman that he has been adopted
and tomorrow will be his last day in the
orphanage the group reunites at night
they're worried about norman who claims
that he would happily die if that meant
everyone else in the orphanage was safe
when everyone is asleep norman finds a
strange pen in his drawer this pen was
kept there by crone to help them escape
the next day norman climbs on the wall
with the help of a rope to run away only
to come across a cliff that he cannot
cross
he returns back to the orphanage and has
accepted his death the group hugs him
for the last time with teary eyes
isabella finally takes him away as emma
cries in agony but to norman's surprise
he is taken to a man instead of a demon
the man claims that he oversees whether
everything goes well in the world of
demons and humans as they talk a demon
arrives in front of norman ready to
devour him for the next few months we
see a depressed emma recovering from her
injury she and rey have lost all hope
and forgotten about their plan to escape
isabella observes them every day and is
happy that they are under control after
two months it is finally rey's turn to
be handed to the demons the night before
emma comes to visit him and tells him
that they still have a chance but rey
has decided to light himself on fire
along with the house as the fire starts
to spread emma cries and calls for
isabella isabella tells the kids to get
out of the house quickly and tries to
put out the fire after a while she
realizes that no kids are around it
turns out that this had been their plan
all along in the past two months emma
couldn't do anything suspicious because
she was being watched by isabella so
instead don and gilda told the other
kids about their plan and prepared them
for it emma also found a letter in
norman's bed that had an elaborate plan
written on it emma couldn't tell rey
sooner because isabella was watching
them closely they have left the little
kids because they couldn't put their
lives in danger emma has promised to
come back for them later when they have
more help now they climb the wall as
isabella approaches them with the help
of the navigator she soon realizes the
navigator isn't working because the
children have removed the device from
their ears finally when everyone is on
top of the wall they tie a rope and
slide through it to the other end emma
is the last one to go but before she can
slide isabella arrives and threatens to
cut the rope emma emotionally tells
isabella that she knows killing the
children has been hard for her isabella
wants to see the children grow and is
actually proud of them for escaping this
far
isabella denies everything emma says and
stays adamant about wanting to get the
kids back emma takes the risk and slides
down the rope isabella has a chance to
cut it
but to their surprise
she doesn't
she watches the kids she raised on the
other side and smiles at them for the
last time
the kids make their way through the
forest they stop when emma tells them
about the pen that crone had left them
the pen projects a picture into the air
upon being opened an owl emerges out of
the image and leads them towards the
city where they will be safe
meanwhile isabella stands in front of
the grandmother and the overseer of both
worlds they are disappointed in isabella
for letting the valuable children run
away at the end of the movie she is fed
to a demon as punishment
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching